the mind of a writer can be a truly
terrifying thing isolated neurotic
caffeine addled crippled by
procrastination and consumed by feelings
of panic self-loathing and soul-crushing
inadequacy and that's on a good day
yes but if everything goes well in the
end there is a screenplay
here are the nominees for Best Adapted
Screenplay Richard Linklater Julie Delpy
and Ethan Hawke four before midnight
based on characters created by Richard
Linklater and clean person Billy Ray for
Captain Phillips based on the book a
captain's Duty Somali pirates Navy SEALs
and dangerous days at sea by Richard
Phillips with Steven torti Steve Coogan
and Jeff Pope for Philomena
based on the both the Rose Tyler
Philomena Lee by Martin Sixsmith
John Ridley for 12 years a slave based
on the book 12 years a slave by Solomon
Northup Terence winter for the world of
Wall Street based on the book by Jordan
Belfort and the Oscar goes to John
Ridley
Oscar for John riff
thank you all I started writing in
sitcoms a long time ago and at that time
I was very fortunate to meet a script
coordinator who was gracious enough to
read everything I wrote and when she
thought it was ready she put a smiling
face at the end that I knew that was job
done I'm Gail seeing here you here
tonight smiling you take away all that
soul-crushing and adequacy all the price
goes to Solomon Northup those are his
words that is his life all the thanks
goes to the entire crew the entire cast
everyone at Fox Searchlight
at River Road at New Regency and Plan B
mr. Pitts most especially to DD and
Jeremy garner
you Jeremy kleiner you made this film
happen Jeremy you made it happen thank
you so much mom dad lisa beth shean
Jason all my love thank you very much
thank you